all right welcome everyone thank you for joining us today and we really appreciate you joining our
web security training for developers session we have some exciting content to share with you
my name is craig i'm a java developer here at port swigger i work on our bub suite enterprise
products i have mark with me as well who is a c sharp.net developer who works on our web team
part of our internal engineering team and before we get started just to let you know we do have a
team working in the background who are standing by to answer your questions if you do have a question
you can use the q a facility which is separate to the chat box just pop your question in there
the team will pick them up and answer them for you we are going to try and answer all of the questions
throughout the session if we get a bit inundated and we don't quite get around to it don't worry
we'll follow up with you after the session and we'll also be making all the questions available
as a document afterwards and we'll be sending you a copy of the slides with all the links in
for further information so you should be able to just sit back enjoy and ask as you go as we go along
um we're actually going to cover today um is talk through what dastardly is and how it can help you
as a developer um we'll talk you through how to deploy dastardly into your ci cd pipelines and
mark's going to give us a demo of doing that with um github actions and we'll talk through a couple of
security issues uh that data they can find out of the seven key security issues that it is possible for
it to find um so dastardly is port swigger's latest offering and it's the first one that same
specifically at helping developers produce more secure software by introducing security testing
into your build pipelines some of you might already be using static application security testing tools
or sast tools like semgrep in your pipelines and or you might be familiar with running other static
analysis tools like check style or style cop and static analysis tools work by examining your source
code and looking for real violations in the case of check style or style cop those rules are your
coding standards in the case of sast tools like semgrep they look for patterns that could lead to
security vulnerabilities and dastardly is different um dastardly is a dynamic application security
testing tool or a dast tool hence dastardly and that means that it runs against your deployed site or
application and attempts to prove that exploitable security vulnerabilities actually exist in your
application rather than just being a pattern that could lead to a vulnerability and dastardly uses the
same industry-leading browser-powered scanning engine that our commercial products do but we've
packaged it up in a way that makes it easier to integrate into your cicd pipelines that can give you
results within 10 minutes or less like that we'll find seven different kinds of security issue
most importantly it's completely free so there's no restrictions on how many apps you can scan
or how many scans you can run with it and the advantages of dastardly are that it's platform
agnostic you can run it anywhere that you can run a container so it's not tied to any specific cicd
pipeline or tool it's programming language and technology stack agnostic as well so it because
they just got it because it scans your deployed web application it doesn't care how you built that
application or what language or framework you used for it and it only requires the bare minimum of
configuration basically you tell us what to scan which url you want us to start at and that's what
you need to do the results are presented in j unit format which most ci tooling can render into a nice
report for you the findings are typically reproducible and actionable and we have remediation advice
provided directly in the report itself the advantage of running this type of scan in your pipelines is
that you then can find vulnerabilities close to the point at which they're actually injected
and just like with unit testing or any other kind of pipeline testing that reduces the amount of time
you need to spend investigating and remediating the issues because you've got a much better idea of the
point at which those defects were injected and because it's using the same engine as your security
team or your external pen tester are likely to be using you're going to be able to find and fix issues
long before they begin their testing which frees them up to find and remediate more critical bugs
they might be trickier to find so i'll hand you over to mark so you can actually see dastardly in action
using github actions thank you craig hi everybody uh my name is mark i'm a dotnet developer and i work
in the web team here at port swigger so we have responsibility for the public website that you'll
find at portswigger.net and also some web endpoints like uh registration and updates for the burp suite
tools as well as a whole host of internal tools that we use here within ports we get to kind of power
the business um so what that means is unlike craig and his colleagues on the burp suite product teams
i'm not a security specialist by trade my background is all dotnet web development um so i was excited to
have a try of dastardly um see what it could teach me about vulnerabilities in my website and figure out
how to integrate it into my cicd pipeline um i like the thought that it would fail the build if it
finds a vulnerability in exactly the same way as i'm used to a failing unit test or integration test
failing the build and therefore would kind of alert me to problems a bit sooner um you know typically
you in my background i've worked in situations where application security is not really the concern
of the development team it maybe belongs further downstream with a dedicated appsec team or as part
of the qa function so what i've got to show you today is a very simple application that has some
deliberate vulnerabilities in it um there's a uh that the site is hosted in github and it's built
with a github actions workflow so we'll take a look at the code that's had to be written in order to
integrate dastardly into that we'll take a look at the site and see what it does and demonstrate what
vulnerabilities we're looking for when we scan it and then we'll take a look at the results of a build
and show you what dastardly is able to find for us and how it displays that to us um so let me switch
over to uh here i'm going to actually start in github so here's my github project for the website
this happens to be written in dotnet with c sharp but as craig has already mentioned dastardly is um
language agnostic so um that we're not going to be looking at anything c sharp or dotnet specific in
this session this would everything we're showing you today is equally applicable uh whatever stack
or language you're using um and likewise although i'm using github actions to build this the techniques
that you're seeing today work well across a full range of ci um frameworks so the first thing i will
do is make a small change to the site um let's just add the word here into the readme file and that will
trigger a build um so we can go and take a look at the github actions tab and we should find a build
has been queued up there it is so that's going to start running in the next few seconds and so while
that's busy i'll demonstrate the site to you and show you um show you what that site does so as you
can see it's a very very basic website it's got two pages apart from this welcome page the first page
has across site scripting or xss vulnerability the second page has a cross origin resource sharing or
cause vulnerability um craig's going to go into a lot more detail later on after the demo about what
those what those are um the cause page is fairly basic and kind of hard to demonstrate visually
um but much easier to demonstrate in this session is the cross-site scripting vulnerability so we've
got a very simple page here with a text input and a submit button and when we add a message to the page
if the demo gods are smiling there you go the message just gets added to a list of messages at the
bottom of the page but the problem here is that we're not sanitizing that input and we're just
adding it to the page as raw html so if i had an html tag in there and submit again we should see
that we had some bold text added to the bottom of the page it's decided to stop behaving itself for a
minute this did happen when we practiced earlier as well so don't worry about that there it is but now
let's take a look at what happens if we add some javascript into there and submit that and that is
the vulnerability that this website um suffers from and what we're hoping that dastardly can find for us
so instead of just adding plain text to the website it's injected some javascript into the page and run
it in the browser and obviously it's a very trivial example here but you could very easily imagine that
technique being used to steal some customer session details or um you know other other sensitive
information so let's switch back to github and we'll take a look at what we had to do in order to
integrate dastardly into this build um i'm using github actions if you're not familiar with github actions
um it uses yaml syntax to declare the build steps that you want to carry out on your repo
um very very similar looking to a range of other ci pipelines that you might be familiar with like
circle ci and things like that so even if you haven't seen github actions before um everything
you're seeing here will be pretty applicable to to whatever you're using um there's three sections to
this build the three uh parts to the build which are known as jobs in github actions the first one
starting there at line 10 is the build and test step so this is using the dotnet command line tools to
build the project and publish it into a um a sort of deployable package the second step which starts
down here on line 38 the second job is to deploy that to microsoft azure and we're just deploying to
a simple free web app um for for the purposes of this demo uh but then the third and you might notice
the smallest section down here at the bottom is the part that scans with dastardly um so there's about
17 lines of fairly simple to follow yaml in there and in fact the four lines in the middle there the
core of it is these four lines here 67 to 70. so what those lines are doing is getting the dastardly
github action from the github marketplace so that's a pre-packaged um action provided by ports figure
and executing it with one input which is the url of the site that we want to scan
so that's actually all you need to run dastardly those four lines at the bottom there um that will
introduce dastardly to your build pipeline it will cause the build to fail if dastardly finds a problem
in it the the extra bit we've got below that is just kind of an added extra really um and this is
recommended in the documentation for dastardly which you'll find on our website and on on the github
marketplace it's just adding us a nicely formatted j unit test report um as an output to that step so
it gives you a lot more information about what dastardly finds and it formats in a really nice
readable fashion so we'll see that in a couple of minutes so that is it literally those um 17 lines
of code were all i needed to add to this project to add a dastardly scan um there's nothing to install
nothing to license there are no uh environment variables or secrets need to be declared elsewhere
in the project it's literally exactly what you're seeing highlighted on the screen there um so that's
all the code we're going to look at we'll just switch back now to the actions tab and yes fortunately
our build has completed you see that it took exactly four minutes um and the builders failed
and it's interesting to note on this page this is showing a history of builds run on this repo back
when the repo was first created and we only had one job in the workflow which was to build and run all my
tests the build passed and we got a green build there and likewise when i added the next step to deploy to
azure we were still getting green builds have a quick look at that you can see that build and test and
deploy to azure both working fine um so it's only when we added dastardly to the pipeline that we
started getting problems reported and i think it's fair to say for a lot of web developers um those steps
of building running our tests and deploying tends to be the extent of our build pipeline at times
so let's see what dastardly has added to that by clicking into this latest build and we can see
immediately there's a third step in the build there the first two steps have passed again the build
has worked the tests have passed the deployment to azure has been successful but now we've got a
problem found by dastardly and there's a little bit of information at the bottom of the screen of
what it's found it's found though the vulnerabilities on both those pages on the site and if we click
through into the build step we can see the raw build log and let's not scroll straight past that
because apart from some absolutely beautiful ascii art at the top there to delight you with every build
we've got details of the arrow down at the bottom there um it's fairly short it's fairly terse it
doesn't tell us a great deal but it does tell us that it found vulnerabilities and it's enough to fail
the build and cause it to go red um but up here on the left you can see a different representation of our
build steps and we'll take a look now at this fourth step and this is going to correspond to
that additional optional uh chunk of config right at the bottom of our yaml file so this is the kind of
nicely formatted j unit test that craig and i both mentioned and you can see it's run some tests so nine of
its checks have passed but three have failed we've got a sort of dashboard view of those three problems
and if we click on raw output under there and take a look in at the the full output that dastardy's
produced you can see some real added value in here apart from this summary uh section at the top where
it tells us what vulnerability it found how severe that vulnerability is and whereabouts on the site
it found it it adds a whole load of detail below that which for me particularly as a web developer was
was really valuable and and uh you know kind of very useful to me it's giving me a load of detail
about the issue it's found the background of that issue um what makes it so severe and also a
recommended remediation for fixing that kind of problem so um this is the kind of information you'll
find for free also on our web security academy over at the ports figure website but here it's kind of
they're writing our build so um when we see a build has failed and we we step into that to investigate why
it's giving us i'm sure you agree quite a lot more information than you your average build failure
so it's kind of educating us as web developers on application security issues and hopefully kind of
helping us to become better developers as a result uh so that's it that's all i had to demonstrate to
you today we've seen dastardly in action on a site where we can all see there's a demonstrable
problem and we've seen the results that dastardly is able to produce for us um just to remind you that
the q a function um which is separate to the chat function in zoom is still active and we've got a
whole support team uh taking your questions so if there are any questions off the back of that demo
please do share them on the q a and someone will get back to you and for now i'll just hand you
straight back over to craig to uh carry us on with the presentation thanks mark so as we saw in mark's
demo xss and cores are two of the uh security issues found by dastardly in our vulnerable website so some
of you may already be familiar with what xss and cores are but for those who who aren't already familiar
we're going to give you a quick high-level overview of what they are and what impact they can have
on users of your web applications so we start out with cross-site scripting and this allows an
attacker to execute arbitrary javascript in a victim's browser as mark demonstrated this potentially
allows the attacker to carry out actions that their victim is able to perform and to access their data
so we're specifically looking at reflected xss in this case and these exploits occur when an attacker
creates a malicious url that we have up here and then uses email or social engineering tricks typically
to lure the victims into visiting that url when the victim clicks the link they unwittingly reflect
their malicious content through the vulnerable web application back onto their own computers and then
the malicious script can perform actions as that user as the victim and that allows them to potentially
access the user's personal information such as card details or other things like that or to take over
their account by stealing session cookies so if you have a quick look at how you might uh inject one of
these vulnerabilities into your application by accident we've got a little bit of template code here that
takes an employee id number from the request and then reflects it back into the page and it does so
without doing any kind of escaping or sanitization so some web frameworks will automatically escape or
sanitize that for you but not everyone's using those frameworks and there are cases where that escaping
can be disabled or it can fail without us as developers even knowing that somebody else somewhere else
has done that so just relying on the fact that he's going to do that for you automatically is obviously
not as good as testing that it is happening correctly in your pipelines so if an attacker was
able to inject some javascript into the page like this and then they'd be able to siphon off session
cookies which then allows them access to the victim's authenticated session and that's how they can
perform actions as if they were that particular user um cross-site scripting is extremely common in the
wild in 2020 it accounted for more bug bounties than any other security vulnerability and it comes under
uh injection on the oas top 10 vulnerabilities and injections currently number three in that list so
again it's very high high profile and high priority um when they tested websites found 94 of websites
they tested were vulnerable to some form of injection and three percent of those sites had been exploited in
that manner and there's a list of household names underneath of companies that have publicly disclosed
access vulnerabilities in the past so it's not just uh also you know we think we might be um in a smaller
development team or a smaller company i think we might get these things wrong even the big guys get
it wrong from time to time so testing and making sure that you're not vulnerable is obviously the way to go
and so the other um issue that we found in the vulnerable app was across origin resource sharing or
cause vulnerability a cause is a browser mechanism that allows controlled access to resources that are
located outside of a given domain so it's useful or it's needed for um interacting with subdomains or
with third-party sites but it does provide the potential for cross-domain attacks if a website's cause
policy is poorly configured or poorly implemented so if you have a look at this example we've got an
application that needs to provide access to other domains um the sort of right way to do this would
be to maintain a list of allowed domains but then you need to maintain that list and you need to make
sure that if you want to give access to another site you've got to add things if a domain changes you
need to make sure that you update the list to do that so what the developers have done in this case
is they've taken the easy route and effectively allowed access from any domain by reflecting the origin
header back into the response so here we can see that we're allowing the origin from our malicious
websites uh worse still they have also set the allowed credentials header to true and that means
that those cross origin requests or requests from the malicious website uh can also include cookies and
be processed in session so armed with this knowledge an attacker can exfiltrate any sensitive
information such as api keys or csrf tokens from the response using a little bit of javascript like we
have here and then go on to kind it caused all kinds of havoc um if you want to know more about these and
other web security vulnerabilities you can check out the web security academy as mark mentioned before
it's another free resource that portswigger offer with loads of information and advice about web security
and all these types of vulnerabilities and there's also a bunch of free sandbox labs on there that you can
experiment with to get yourself more familiar with what these kind of vulnerabilities are and how attackers
use them and so hopefully that's given you some insight into what dastardly does and how what it can
provide to you um if you want to give it a go um definitely we have a whole bunch of deployment
instructions not just for github actions but also for team city and for uh jenkins as you mentioned
earlier on is platform agnostic it's basically on a container so anywhere you can run a container you
can run this um hopefully you have enough information to go on to deploy uh dastardly into your pipelines
both from the presentation which will send you a copy of and also um from the resources that are linked
and we have a little uh dare for you a little challenge for you to take on so as uh mark demoed it is
really quick and easy to to integrate so there's no specific um required platform requirements for
this what we'd like you to do is see how quickly you can deploy dastardly into your ci cd pipeline
whatever that is whether it's one of the ones we have um deployment instructions for or something else
and if you could record and send in a video of how quickly it takes you and you can post a view the
video on youtube if you like and send us the link to it we'll then review these and the fastest
implementations will win some free dastardly swag so hopefully that's been useful for you all and
just before we close out today we have a couple of poll questions that we would like you to answer
uh so we'll give you a few minutes to answer those and then we will close out
you
okay that's great thank you for your uh feedback we'll obviously take that on board like we said
we will send out a copy of the slides and a copy of the q a and we're going to hold the question and
answer session open for the next 10 minutes so if you still have a question you haven't had a chance to
ask yet feel free to uh chuck that in there and our amazing colleagues will be more than happy to
answer them for you and we'll see you again soon and let us know how you get on with dastardly thanks very much